Today. We are so excited to have Dr
Francesca Gino here joining us. She is,
I'm a behavioral scientist and the
Tandon family professor of business
administration at Hbs,
Harvard Business School.
And she will be talking to us
about some of her recent research,
which is also represented in her
new book called rebel talent.
And I am told that one of the rebels,
so they'll be talking about is a
fabulous Italian chef. So among others.
So we have lots of good stuff in
store. So Francesca, come on up. Um,
she's gonna talk yeah,
for about 45 minutes.
Thank you.
45 minutes of content and
save your questions. Um, if
you're on the live stream,
please feel free to ping them to Al Rahim
Murali who's ELDAP as a l a h I m and
we will go from there.
Perfect. Thank you so much. Welcome.
Thank you so much for having me and thank
you so much for all of you to show up
and come to the talk.
As you heard,
we're going to talk about some of the
ideas in the book and I want to share some
stories,
a little bit of the research behind the
scenes and all fully you're going to
feel as inspired as I felt when I
was working on this book project.
And I want to start with a story that I
heard and I was told by going went back
to the restaurant by the person who
works at this a three Michelin Star
restaurant in needle is called Osteria
Francescana there in modern, um,
and his name is [inaudible].
And this is actually the story of a family
of four who visited the restaurant on
a Friday night.
So imagine your father and mother and
eight year old boy and a 14 year old boy
and Palmieri helps them find their table
and then shows up to take the order.
And the father are incredibly happy,
makes an order for each one of the four
of them for a tasting menu that has a 13
dishes and he's called sensations
and it's almost lunch time.
So I want to give you a sense of the
type of dishes that are part of them is
menu, so quite creative in
the way they were assembled.
That's a Yo and other dish
that is part of these 13 um,
tasting menu course.
Tasting menu is the one that you see here.
It looks like a funny ice
cream but that's a four gras,
so not the type of dishes the
growing boys would hunger for.
Now the fiber was so eager to eat
at the restaurant and not only me,
the reservations for Friday night.
You also made the reservations
for Saturday night.
So there's now 24 hours later the same
families back at the restaurant and we're
again welcomes them in a,
brings them to their table and
then shows up to take the order.
This time again very happily,
the father goes a four at 10 cores,
a tasting menu called the
tradition in evolution.
And again I want to give you a sense of
the type of that are part of the manual.
One of them is called his nails and
under the earth he served as a soup,
but there actually is nails at the bottom
of the plate and they're hidden under
a form of raw garlic and
potato and the earth.
Part of the dish is stands for
black truffle coffee and nuts.
Now I'm Permian was taking the ordered,
you notice that the boys over most had
a face of disappearing as if they were
not sharing the eagerness and excitement
of their father to have another gourmet
meal and the boys were keeping quiet.
But Palmieri turn to the eight
year old at the table and said,
what would you like to have pizza
that the year old boy now is we,
everyone just going is no pizzeria.
There is no way you could find pizza
on their menu and it's a rather serious
place. Fresh flowers are brought
into the restaurant every day.
The tables are put together
with surgical precision.
The dishes are arranged with a lot
of attention to detail and this is a
restaurant. The back in 2016 became the
best restaurant in the world. And in fact,
also this year in 2018 they were
back at the top of the list.
But despite all of that,
when premire heard pizza is skills
themselves ran to the phone,
called up the best pizzeria
moderner and order the pizza.
And sure enough about 1520 minutes later,
a pizza showed up and the door in a taxi
and pizza was served that to the boys.
Now I'm telling you this story
because it's a perfect example of war.
Rebel talent is all about even in
situations where there are lots of rules,
as in the case of fancy restaurant,
permia was able to keep his mind open,
look at the problem from a different
perspectives and come up with a rather
creative solution.
So what I want to suggest is that we all
probably want to be people like Palmyra.
If we think about our
leadership broadly defined,
the people that we influence in
our different spheres of life,
whether at work or in our personal life,
I would say that we want to have people
would order the pizza like Palmieri dead
in that particular instance.
Now,
what's interesting is that I will call
[inaudible] area rabble for this behavior
for many other behaviors that you engage
in on a regular basis in his work,
but rebels usually have a bad reputation.
I spend a lot of time in organizations
and I've collected all sorts of words for
them.
They're called the show offs.
Sometimes they're called the jerks or
the annoying people who slow you down in
your decision making processes.
The trouble makers, the outcasts.
In fact,
I think that we often have a very precise
idea of the rebels in the business.
We think about people like
apple, visionary, Steve Jobs,
so people are incredibly innovative and
creative, but at least the stories go,
not the type of people
you want to work with,
the or AV as a boss or as an employee.
And what I want to do in the
time that we have together,
and it was a big motivation for writing
this book is trying to shift that
thinking and suggest that people who I
call a rabbles are not people to break
rules just for the sake of breaking rules.
They are not people who are arrogant.
There are people who break rules,
hold them and others back and they
break rules in a way that is very
constructive and productive and
positive for their organizations.
So that said,
let me share a few stories that are going
to allow us to talk about what are the
ingredients of their success and the
first story that they want to share comes
up from the domain of sport.
Now some of you might know this
guy is a rather well known coach.
His name is Marisa cheeks and I want to
tell him particular about the evening of
April 23rd the 2003 this
was a big night for him.
It was game three of the first
round of the 2003 NBA championships.
And I like you to imagine being there.
You're in a very big arena,
20,000 fans ready to watch the game.
You're there with them,
ready to cheer up your team to success.
Millions of viewers are from home
and before the game started at girl,
Ooh, as about 14 years in
age, stepped into the arena,
ready to sing the national anthem.
And what I like you to do is watch a
video clip that I brought with me of that
moment and I like you to pay
attention to what this coach does. Oh,
why don't we do the following.
We'll come back to add that and I'm
gonna talk about a different ingredients
first a where we don't need to
look at the video quite yet.
The second ingredient that seems to be
something to rebels do quite well is
having a great desire for
challenge and for novelty.
And I want to introduce this ingredient
by telling you about a personal story.
It is Christmas time, a few
years back and our house, and
this is not what happened there.
I had what I thought was the
perfect gift for my husband.
And the only thing that you need to know
about him is that is the type of person
who would be super happy to work here.
So it's a complete geek,
so always loves the new piece of
technology. Uh, the lead is gadget.
Everything that is a interesting and
playful when it comes to technology is the
perfect gift for him. And so on
Christmas Day, he runs downstairs.
There is a big tree in the living room
and under the tree finds a big box that I
prepare the for him and it takes the
top off and then he start taking some
pieces of paper out of the box.
There was this card at the bottom of the
box letting you know that they signed
us up for a 10 week,
two hour weeks course in Improv comedy.
Now,
as it turns out in pro carbonate taught
me all sorts of interesting things that
are really good lessons for life in
thinking about the work that we do,
in thinking about the relationship
that we have and in the spirit of, uh,
bringing to bear something that
I've learned by taking this class,
I thought that we could
do an exercise together.
That is one of the exercises that we did
quite a few times throughout, uh, Improv.
Now. Um, just to close the story, my,
my husband was too happy when
I signed him up for this class.
He really wanted the latest gadget in
his hands, but I thought it was wrong.
And by the end of the first
two hour class, he actually
told me that he hated it.
But things started to change as we
went on and on for our weekly classes.
And he started really enjoying having
this a date with the anesp acted.
So I'm going to ask each of you, if you
don't mind to stand up for this exercise.
I'm going to ask each of
you to find the partners.
So a person who is a
standing close to you,
that would work well. Perfect. And
I'm gonna put myself up here so
that you can see the direction.
So this is not too difficult.
Okay.
I'm going to ask you to stand about
this distance from your partner.
That is a,
somebody over here needs a partner since
you're working in pair and if you don't
have a partner you can also work
with me. I'm fine with that. Okay,
so here's what I'm going to ask you to do.
From that position,
you're going to standing
in front of your partner.
I'm going to ask you to spend the next
20 seconds and I'm going to keep the time
for you staring in the
eyes of your partner. Okay?
And there are a few more rules
before you get started. No laughing,
no talking,
no anything.
No really expression of any
emotions on your face. Okay,
so that's the agro sizes.
I said I'm going to keep the time for you.
And when there is silence you can start.
Okay.
And time.
How did that feel?
It was great.
Okay. For some of you,
maybe slightly awkward,
a little bit weird,
uncomfortable.
As it turns out, if you felt a little
bit awkward, slightly uncomfortable,
that's okay.
It means that you're human because our
brain knows that if we stand that close
to a person looking in their
eyes for that amount of time,
one or two things usually happen.
One, we're going to kiss the person.
Two, we're going to punch
them in the face and I,
I don't want any of that
to happen on Google.
So you can go to your partner
and shake their hands and say,
I'm not going to punch you. I'm
not going to kiss you. Okay,
now that that is out of the
way, no, no, no. Standing up,
not sitting yet. There is a
second part of the exercise. Now,
a beautiful principle of Improv is the
idea of who is working on scenes with a
partner and shifting your
attention from us to them.
Our goal in scenes is always trying
our best to make our partner feels good
about what they're doing or feeling as
confident as they can feel about what
they're doing. And again, what a beautiful
lesson about life more generally.
And so to practice that, we're going
to go back to the same position again.
I'm going to ask you to engage in
this 22nd of a period of steering,
but this time you're also
trying to pay attention.
So what is their eye color?
Is their haircut an interesting one
or are their ears shaped in a slightly
different way? Whatever you want
to do, you're trying to stare,
but pay attention to what they're doing.
Okay. Same rules, same rules as before.
So no talking, no laughing, no
facial expression of any kind.
Okay, perfect. If you're ready, let's go
and time.
Okay,
we're going to test what are you
going or paying attention or not?
Seems like that you were, I know. Oh,
that sounds like a common from my husband.
As we were going to classes,
you're going to turn around 180
degrees and so each one of you,
so this time is not your
face looking at their face,
but it's your back looking at their back.
Perfect.
And what I'm going to ask you to do is
each one of you to think about two big
changes.
So I don't know if you have glasses,
you might want to take your
glasses off or rough up your hair,
be as creative as you want to be,
and then make those two
changes on yourself. Okay.
No taking off clothes,
just
perfect. Okay. If you
have your two changes,
when you're ready,
you can turn around and each of you can
guess the changes that you see in your
partner.
Okay.
Are you able to figure them out?
Yeah.
Again,
it's quite nice to be able to shift the
attention from ourselves to the other
partner.
So hopefully most of you were able to
see the changes the other person actually
made. Now I'm going to do that final part
of this exercise. And do we have music?
Are we good with audio?
Yeah. Perfect. Okay.
We're going to do the final
part of the eggs this size.
And this is what I'm going to
ask you to do if you don't mind.
Um, do you like to dance? Yes. Yes. Oh.
If I were to find you on a dance floor,
what you would be doing? Dancing. Okay.
Can you show,
can you show me one of your moves?
Yes. I generally have like
you have generally. Okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
This is what I am seeing.
So something else, sorry.
The much better than what I'm doing,
but it's something around that. Okay.
So your role as an, again, each
of you is going to do this,
that you end up here,
each of you is going to think
about their favorite dance move.
And I'm going to put on some music and
ask you to actually try it out in front
of your partner. And then you're
going to switch when I say switch.
But here's the very important
role of the partner.
Since your task is to make your partner
feel as good as they can feel about
their dancing in this case,
or as confident as they can
feel about their dancing,
you're mirroring but exaggerating.
Okay?
So whatever it is,
I don't know what I would do this here,
but in a way that really makes them feel
good about the way they are dancing.
Okay. Um, as I said, I'm going to put up
some users since it's easier to dance.
That way you can decide
who's gonna go first.
Yeah.
And when you're ready,
the first person can start,
Michelle.
Okay.
Hey,
plus do all of you can take it.
[inaudible]
I'm
really exceptional dancing in this room.
I have to say I'm very,
I'm very impressed.
How did that feel compared to the first
exercise when you were staring the first
time you did that much better.
Right?
It's interesting that once we put
ourselves out there in situations where we
feel challenged,
where we're always doing something new,
it becomes easier to feel
comfortable with the uncomfortable.
That's what rebel often do.
You know,
I was obviously very interested
in studying this idea in
the case of businesses.
And so I want to businesses to try to see
how is it that they injected this idea
of challenge and novelty
in the work that people do.
And one of the businesses I visited
where I expected not to find any
rebelliousness is a fast food chain in
the middle of tenancy in West Virginia.
They look like this.
They're drives through bleed blue,
big blue boxes with French fries
and hot dogs on their roof,
but then have quite successful
at what they do. In fact,
if you look at any measure of performance,
revenue per square, you name it,
they beat the competition by far.
And we're talking about big brands
like Mcdonald's, Burger King, Wendy's.
Now they also invest in
people quite differently.
So if a police like Mcdonald's,
you receive an hour and a half,
two hours of training
per stations at Paul's,
they give you 135 hours
of training per station.
So they're really all about making you
an expert such that you have the free
space in your mind to think about how
to improve on the work that you do.
Now, when I was there, I was in the middle
of the store, actually a rush hours.
And so you see people working at their
stations almost like machines and that
sort of thing. And then maybe work
becomes monotonous or even boring.
And yet the general managers
of thought about this,
and so it's more ways
that they inject novelty.
One way in which they do
this is that the idea of, um,
letting people know the order that they're
going fall, look throughout the day,
the stations that they're moving
from to one, they show up for work.
So they created a little
bit of unpredictability,
a little bit of novelty that
allows them to stay on their feet.
And what's also interesting is that they
have all sorts of challenges for the
people working in the stores.
My favorite to date is a challenge
for the person working at the windows.
So the person who takes the order,
an interesting statistic about pals is
that they have a lot of repeat customers.
So people who eat there five to six
times a week and they have a simple menu.
And so people are creatures of habit,
tend to make the same order
whenever they show up.
And so the challenge for the
person at the window wounds,
if you can remember a hundred orders
in a row, then there is this reward.
And it was really interesting to see
how the person really experienced it as
being pushed in the work that she did.
And she was very happy when she actually
completed the challenge successfully.
So what is very true about Rabil is,
is that they have this desire for novelty.
They're not afraid of putting
themselves in situations that makes them
uncomfortable.
Now let's go back to the first ingredient
with the video that I want to do,
show you earlier. So you know
the setup. And as I said,
the idea is for you to think about how
you'd feel if you were in the shoes of
this coach. When went to watch
the video, maybe, maybe not.
Who knows a little bit of
novelty, um, and see what he does.
Pay attention to his behavior
and Alex, your water America. Absolute,
the men and women serving our
country with our national anthem.
Please welcome as voted by you.
The fans are a winner of the Toyota.
Get the feeling of a star promotion.
Natalie Gilbert.
Oh, say, can you see
the
what?
Hey. Ah, the stars law.
Stop Stars.
Ooh,
Scott's trial.
Bye.
Oh, the whoa.
Yay.
Eh.
Well the,
Eh,
now let me ask you a question.
Does this guy have a good voice?
Absolutely not.
And yet it took him no time to stop
in the middle of the arena and start
singing,
helping the girl who needed help.
What is impressive about him is that
he has no problem making themselves
vulnerable.
Even one that means showing everybody
that clearly singing is not one of his
strengths but rather it's a weakness and
that's what rebel's seems to be doing
quite naturally.
They make themselves vulnerable in a
way that is not back firing as we often
think you will but rather buys
them a lot of respect. In fact,
if you didn't feel moved in a little way,
at least the watching that I think you
have no heart because it really creates
an emotional connections by doing
what he does it. So as I said,
rebels that are people who seems to be
quite a happy to jump in and to help.
Now, they also are people, as I said,
that they have this
interesting desire for novelty.
But I want to share a couple of more
of their ingredients. And again,
we're going to go back to the domain
of sport and we're not going to look at
this guy bleeding.
We're going to see a little boy,
younger boy getting
into the bees will feel.
And I'd like you to pay attention to the
reframing. Daddy does quite naturally
strike one
strike two.
Why is the greatest hitter
strike three?
Wow.
Now this little guy is very impressive.
We all tend to dwell on our weaknesses.
We often over invest in our weaknesses
and instead he shifts his attention to
his strengths. And as it turns
out, that's what rebels do.
They play to their strengths on a regular
basis and that's something that makes
them feel authentic in
the work that they do.
I was very curious about this
idea of authenticity. There
is a lot of talking, uh,
in the world about the
power of authenticity.
And I was interested in looking at whether
a lot of the things that we say about
authenticity or true and so
with my colleagues we went
to all sorts of contexts
to look at whether authenticity is in
fact a powerful driver in the work that we
do. So one of the contexts that we
explored is entrepreneurial competitions.
So imagine entrepreneurs
showing up, pitching their
ideas to venture capitalists.
And what we found is that
when entrepreneurs are
authentic and genuine in their
pitching, they're three times more
likely to get money for their ideas.
Now as in these,
there is also an interesting part of
this story of the chef and owner of the
restaurant that I mentioned earlier,
Osteria Francescana, you can see him here.
His name is Massimo Bottura.
Really interesting person and leader.
In fact, it is a person
and went to a context that
traditional Italian dishes and
reinvented them. Now I don't know
how much you know about Italians,
but there are two things
that are very true.
One is that there are lots of
rules when it comes to cooking.
And we cherish our old ways.
And he went to a context where
there are lots of traditions.
So were recipes have been passed on for
centuries from generation to generation.
And he basically messed up the tradition
and came up with something new.
So we studied traditions very carefully
and then started asking question,
well maybe made sense. Um, cooking this
dish this way 20 years ago, but not today.
Let's do something different.
So if you have ever had Lasagna,
this is his version of the Lasagna is
called the crunchy part of the Lasagna.
It looks nothing like the
type of dishes I grew up with.
Now what is interesting is that when you
open the restaurant traditional moment,
Italians weren't too happy.
In fact,
he talks about it as actively
fighting against him.
And when I asked him what
allowed him to stay persistent,
you told me about the
power of authenticity.
And in fact you told me about the story
of the summer that he spent at the bully
at the time,
quite a famous restaurant in Spain.
And what he learned from the chef there.
And it was really a message of feeling
the freedom and expressing the freedom of
playing to your strength
and staying authentic.
And so this is the quote is that what
changed me was the message of freedom.
The foreign gave me the
freedom to feel my own fire,
to look inside myself and
make my thoughts. I dibble.
And sure enough after the
summary went back to Moderna,
he sold everything that he had.
You borrow money from his wife's family
and then invested the money and the time
in the restaurants came up with the
recipes and a few months later the first
Michelin Star arrive and the
second one and the third.
And as I told you in 2016 the
restaurant became the restaurant.
The best restaurant in the world and of
Italian pride is since it was the first
time when you tell your restaurant
reached the top of the list. Now again,
his interest,
his story's interesting,
but as a scientist I was curious
to know whether he's stories more
generalizable.
The idea that authenticity is really
powerful to help us persistence through
challenges.
So one of the studies that we conducted
to look at this is by bringing red sox
facts into HBS campus.
And what we did,
we gave them, um, one type,
one or two types of wristbands to where
either the wristband of their favorite
team, the red sox, or the
wristbands of the New York Yankees.
And then we put them through all sorts
of challenges in the hour that we had
with them.
And at the very end,
one of the challenges was to ask them to
put their dominant hand in a bucket of
ice.
And so we were paying them the longer
they kept their hand in a bucket of ice.
We were interested in seeing
whether a UC persistence,
more persistent when people
experience authenticity,
even in the case of tolerance
to pain and physical persistent.
And sure enough across all the different
challenges we put them through people
who felt authentic just for wearing the
wristband of their favorite team or much
more likely to persist through challenges
even when he came to keeping their
hands in the bucket of ice
at the end of this study.
So just in their authenticity is really
quite powerful in helping us resist the
through challenges.
Now what this tells us,
and the reason why I'm telling you
these stories is that they are quite
interesting in showing one of the
talents the rebels seem to have.
There are people who play to
their strength quite often,
but they also help others do the same.
A few years back,
I came across a quote of an
Italian sculptor, an artist.
They're really stayed with me. You
probably know some of his work. Um,
his name is Michela Angelo Buena Bonati.
Heres what you wrote about
the sculpting processes.
Sad sculpting is a process whereby the
artist releases and ideal figure from the
block of stone in which is lumbers.
To me that's very powerful because it
raises the question of what if we were to
look around in our professional lives
at work or in our personal lives and
starting with the assumptions
that fundamentally everybody
has talent and that
our role as colleagues,
as leaders,
as parents, as friends, is
to help them bring those out.
So I bought into this idea and then I
started the questions asking question of
how do we do that concretely.
And so I'm going to leave you with a
couple of examples that maybe my trigger,
some suggestions or ideas in your head.
The first story comes
from Ariel investment.
This is a Chicago based money management
firm and the president of Ariel
investment is the woman that you see in
the picture. Her name is Mellody Hobson,
remarkable woman,
really successful,
really interesting what she does to
bring a lot of these talent into your
organization. And when I asked her to tell
me a little bit more about her career,
she told me that she started working
at Ariel at the age of 22 right after
graduating from college,
no working experience.
And she's been quite successful.
So what was the secret to her success?
She referred to the advice that she
received directly from the CEO at the time
on the first day of work, and
this is what this, you told her,
you're going to be in rooms with people
who have a lot of money and have big
titles, but it doesn't mean that your
ideas are not as good or even better.
I want to hear your ideas.
It's incumbent on you to speak up.
So from the very first day she had the
license of bringing our contributions
forward and this is advice that she
shares with everybody at the firm or
everybody that she brings into the firm.
Now back in 2011 I had an opportunity
to think about how to apply these ideas.
I was working with a company
called the Wipro technologies.
They're based in India and in particular
my colleagues and I were working with
their business process outsource
inside of the business.
So imagine people working
in call centers now,
as you might imagine,
it's a tough job.
And in fact what we were was experiencing
was investing a lot in people,
bringing them in and then
45 to 60 days into the job,
most people were leaving the organization,
so not the greatest investment.
And so we did an intervention with them
where we gave people who joined half
hour of reflection. We ask them
to think about their strengths,
to think about what's unique about
them and how they could play to their
strengths more often at work.
And the,
since we wanted to test the ideas and
some of the people actually went through
this revise the welcoming process,
some of them went through the regular
welcoming process and we print them.
We looked at turnover rates seven
months after the intervention.
And what we found is that this moment of
reflections where people had the chance
to think about what makes them authentic
and how they could bring that out into
work was quite powerful.
So people were more likely to be with
the organization seven months later.
There were also much happier in their
jobs and they perform better as we know
from the railings on customers' calls.
And what is interesting,
I think about this study is that it's
in a context where the job is very
scripted,
suggesting that even there,
there is an opportunity for
us to rely on this talent.
So what these different
studies and stories tell us
is that rebels play to their
strengths on a regular basis, but they
also help others do the same. And again,
I felt very inspired by learning about
this in a way that made me think about
work a little bit differently.
So let me share a final ingredient
and then we're going to open it up for
question. This is a,
I think at the moment,
one that really puzzles me and it's a
talent for curiosity and it puzzles me
because we're all born with it.
In fact, if you look at the data,
he curiosity peaks at the age of four
and five and then it declines steadily
from there. I think that that's a
sad finding and a missed opportunity.
And I don't know if you can still remember
the time you were cared is way too
long ago for me.
So I think about my children who are at
the age where curiosity is really coming
out and it's constant questioning.
Just before I left for this trip,
they were asking questions
about why is the sky blue?
Or why is it that we need to wear
clothes when we leave the house?
It's constant exploring and a
sense of wonder and question.
And we seem to be losing that.
And in fact,
when I looked at this in the
context of organizations,
I looked at people who are starting
new jobs across the different sort of
industries. And it seems like
curiosity is pretty high as you start.
But when you go back to the same people,
six to nine months later,
curiosity a dropped across the board by
at least 20% it doesn't have to be that
way. And in fact of rebels or people
who keep their curiosity alive and also
encourage it in others.
So I'll give you a couple of examples.
One comes from intuit.
Every year they have innovation at words.
And these are for people,
a ransom explorations that led to
new products and new processes,
but they also have failure words and
these go to people lose explorations did
not end up in a new product but
led to good learnings for the team.
And what's most exciting about this
example is that the failure of words come
with a failure party.
So you're really creating an atmosphere
where explorations is in fact supported
and valued.
Now we started it with a story about
the restaurant Osteria Francescana.
So we are going to end with a
story about this restaurant.
This is a very busy night
at Osteria Francescana and
one of their sous chef that
is known internally.
A stacker was working on the last dessert
of the night and it was a lemon tart.
Tac has done for being obsessed with
precision and attention to detail.
And so he was working very
carefully arranging the
different pieces on the plate
and all of a sudden the plate drop to
the floor and I yet as mashed a lemon
tart.
Now Taka was starting to panic,
trying to understand and
figure out what to do.
And as it was feeling this way,
chef Massimo Bottura walked into the
kitchen and saw the plate on the floor and
rather than yelling as I bet a lot of
leaders would do in fancy restaurant,
he looked at the plate and said,
I think we have a new item for our money.
And sure enough they came up with a new
dessert is not one of their most popular
desserts at the restaurant.
And um, it looks like this.
I took a picture of when I was there,
it smashed on the play even
in a way that is prepared.
And the name for it is, oops,
I dropped the lemon tart.
And he's just a great example of
how curious people are curious.
Leaders like him are able to even look
at accidents or mistakes and turn them
into a source of inspiration.
So it seems as if these rebels do
have a recipe to their success.
And if you look at how
they use their talents,
there are all sorts of behaviors that
they engage in on a regular basis.
And there are many of them
I write about in the book.
I just captured the fewer of them on the
slides and is not for talking through
them. But just to give you the
idea that a lot of these things,
a lot of these behaviors are not
requiring a complete restructuring of the
organization or rethinking
over what we're doing,
but they require some
thoughtfulness on our part.
Now this rabble shares five talents,
no matter what industry or um,
a job they do. And we talked
about some of them in more detail.
They have this talent for authenticity.
They have a talent for novelty.
Rather than going with the
familiar and comfortable,
they challenge themselves
have a talent for curiosity.
They have a talent for perspective.
A little bit like what Palmieri did.
One looking at the problem rather than
being stuck on the obvious answer,
it looked at it from multiple perspective.
And finally they have
a talent for diversity.
So there are people really reject
social rules that are passed onto us by
society and they think about surrounding
themselves with people who think
differently and can challenge their way
of thinking. And then really leverage,
um, differences. So let me stop here.
I have many more story to tell you,
but I'm kinda curious to see
what questions are on your mind.
Yeah. Before we get into that, let
me just remember or remind you,
if you're on the live stream,
feel free to Ping Al Rahim Murali.
So He's a l e r a, h. I. M.
That we can start with the room.
So that great talk. Um, I'm just curious.
So the literature on creativity shows
that people are most creative under some
level of constraint. Total freedom is
not great for the creative process.
Similarly,
do rebels depend on there
being some shared assumptions
for them to question and
break to some extent?
And does that mean not everyone can
be a rebel in an organization? Right?
There has to be some kind of
shared culture or structure
or something like that
for them to operate best.
Huh.
So, uh, in one of the chapters in the
book that comes a little bit late,
or I talk about the principles the rebels
live by and it was something that was
inspired by, uh, going
potentially to a strange place.
So one of the organizations that they
studied this as it was working on this
book was pirate ships in the 16th century.
They are fascinating and I had all
sorts of wrong ideas about them and the
ships,
the crews actually had principles that
everybody agreed upon before they left
for, uh, uh, for their
journeys. And similarly, uh,
rebels,
the Av principles,
one of them is finding
freedom in constraint.
So you're right in saying that the fact
that that, um, that our structures,
norms, rules allows them to bring
out some of their creativity.
Now to your question of,
does that mean that that affects the
number of rebels that we have in the
organization?
I usually receive the question in the
form of what's the exact percentage of
rebel that I should have
in the organization. And my
answer is always the same.
It makes people feel uncomfortable.
It's 100%.
And the reason is that if
we look at this balance,
there is nothing threatening about them
other than requiring a little bit more
openness to people that bring
into work different perspectives.
And one of the things that is true about
rebels is that you get to being more
innovative,
to perform better in your job,
to have better relationships at work
and because you're fully engaged in the
work that you do.
And so I've been struck by the data that,
um,
is very well known about engagement across
the globe and the fact that there are
two third of workplaces full of people
were disengaged or actively disengaged.
He's just puzzling and strange.
And I've met some of those people
and really the experiences,
the work sucks for many of them.
And so I think that we're
encouraging rebelliousness.
You also get the engagement that
leads to all sorts of benefits.
So a hundred percent
yeah.
You mentioned that, uh, rebels
play to their strengths.
And so I wanted to ask a question related
to growth mindset and fixed mindset.
Um,
so if they're playing to their strengths,
does that mean they're not improving
or building on their weaknesses?
And do you think then,
uh,
wondering if you think it's like not
useful to do that and just like focus on
building more strength?
Yeah,
so I actually think that if you look at
the two talents that I talked about a
capture these idea of,
of learning and growing.
So novelty means putting
yourself out there in situations,
the challenges in a way that
allows you to develop new skills.
And so that's the part
of the growth mindset.
But there is also this idea that you
focus a lot of what you do and gives you
energy.
That is what I mean by playing to your
strengths as a way that makes you feel
outstanding.
So I don't see the two in contradictions.
It seems like rebels do
both quite, uh, quite well.
And one of the things that
are across the board. Um,
I don't use the label
growth mind is as much,
but I use a thirst for learning,
which in a sense it's similar and this
a willingness to grow in their job is,
it's quite important for rebels.
In fact,
some people say what about a organs
where arrogance is not part of their
playbook, but the humility is, um,
I'll give you a quick
story if you don't mind.
And it's in one of the chapters
where I talk about perspective.
The person I mentioned, they're, uh,
they're really surprise me as a captain
that you probably all now and his
captain Sully Sullenberger,
this is the captain who ditch the play
when 155 passenger in the Hudson River
back on a call live in, you know, 2009.
And when I found myself
reading the accident report,
I was amazed by what he did.
You had 280 seconds to make a decisions.
That's the time that he had when he
discovered that there was no thrust in the
engines and the timing ditch
the plane in the Hudson River,
most of us under such time pressure and
stress would narrow our thinking and
options.
He instead was broadening his perspective.
He kept considering what it
is that we could be doing.
And I reached out to him since I
was curious about his approach.
And what I've learned is that by
the time the accident happened,
he had a ton of experience over
30,000 hours of flying under his belt.
He has served in the military,
so he had all sorts of experience flying,
all sorts of planes. He had served
as a volunteer in previous accidents,
so so in knew a lot
about what can go wrong,
but every time he walked into the cockpit
it would ask himself what it is that
could be different. In this case,
what it is that I could learn.
And so he kept that intellectually
melody that I seen a lot of rebels that
allows them to keep looking
at the experience as a signal.
Not that they know it all,
but that there is more to grow and learn.
We have a question from the livestream.
Most of the examples you
shared involve men as rebels.
How do you think that rebellious
behavior is treated when those rebels are
outside of the gender or ethnic majority?
A very good point. And I tried, um,
in the book to actually be
much broader in the sense of,
um,
not only going outside of
the United States but also
having both examples of men
and women as well as
different, uh, groups. Now,
what I collected some data on this,
this since one of the questions that
I always receive is the can a women or
minorities break rules
as much as a white man?
And the answer is that
we perceive they can't.
But actually the benefits of embracing
these talents are equal for men and women
and for all sorts of groups, which
I think is quite refreshing. Um,
for gender. More specifically
ended up after the book came out,
I ended up writing a blog post for HBR
where it talks specifically drawing on a
chapter on the book,
on gender issues.
And sort of giving tips out of the book
of why is it and how is it that women
can, uh, break rules. But yeah,
so we have the perception,
but it's the wrong perception and
we can all break rules equally.
I think we have time.
The legal line.
Thank you for your talk. I'm curious
about the downsides of being a rebel.
So all the examples you gave are
about the upsides and the rewards,
but obviously there's a lot of
inherent risk as you make yourself
more known,
take bigger risks or decisions.
So what research have
you done in that area?
So part of it is the fact that you're
pushing for something different.
And so,
uh,
I think the keys of water is a great
example where you might fights,
have to fight some resistance,
uh, before getting accepted.
But in terms of when is it that they could
really go wrong or when the costs are
really high.
I think that for that it happens
for rebels that are not effective.
And what I mean by this is that often,
especially new organizations,
what do you feel that maybe
the top leadership is not
supporting this approach?
People get frustrated and that frustration
often turns into the wrong delivery
as you're trying to use this talent.
I'm going to give you a concrete example.
So after the book came up as you
don't mind Rumi and a message and sad,
I saw the book, I bought
the book, I read the book.
I think that you need to change
your subtitle. I was like, okay.
It says why you to break the rules working
going in life. And we're scientists.
So I obviously always want to
learn and I might be wrong. Um,
so I called them up and we
had the conversation for
two hours and I basically,
his argument was, I'm the perfect
rebel based on your descriptions,
but things are not working out for me.
And from what he was saying,
I couldn't quite figure it out.
And as it turns out,
his job is right outside of Boston.
And I said,
why don't I come for three
days and follow you at work?
Like a neutral observer in the background.
And I thought you would be a great
experience for me just to learn about is
approved. And after the first half
a day I was like, okay, I get it.
And you was the delivery that was wrong.
I think it was really frustrated by
what the top leadership was encouraging.
And so it was using a lot of arrogance.
So, so for example, in a meeting,
and it was, this was just priceless. Um,
the group was talking about a decision
that the company was considering and
everybody talked before him was agree,
the fact that that it was
the right approach of looking
at this decision and he
was raising his and it was super angry.
And then when he got called on it sad,
I understand what you will sad
and why you might think that way,
but it's actually the wrong way of
approaching the decision. In fact,
I cannot even think of an even more
wrong way of looking at the decision,
what I suggest we do instead. And then he
blurted out his answer and it was just,
um,
in between crying and laughing and seeing
that because the approach was wrong.
So I think that that's
often when things get, um,
a little bit difficult for
people and they encounter costs.
Great. Thank you. I'm sure
we had a lot more questions,
but unfortunately we are out of
time so I'll leave you with that.
If you have extra questions,
you should feel free to reach out.
I'll also leave you with the
following thing, some of you my, um,
feel maybe not at ease with the idea.
And so to get started on this wonderful
journey you might want to go to the book
website is called rebel talent.org.
And there is a little test that tells
you which type of rebel you are.
So which type of talents come
more easily or less easily to you.
And so you're going gonna receive some
tips and if you come out as a pirate,
it's a good thing.
It's actually quite a very good thing.
So thank you so much.
Thank you so much.